I love me some cheese
I love cheese more than I love some
people the stinky are the better I like
cheese yeah but I don't usually get that
adventurous with it at the stinkiest
cheese I've eaten is free and that's not
even really that stinky you know some
people have wine cellars I just want a
cellar full of different types of
cheeses can you say I just got a huge
whiff of that so we're supposed to eat
the mold if I went on a first date in
someone's breath smelled like this I
would immediately run away but really
maybe he's just really refined it's got
a nice gooey texture oh it's really good
sounds like a foot fungus is it weird
that I like the taste of that I would
put this into my cheese cellar slosh
slosh las it's got the mold hairs which
is this hot dog come on man this one's
gonna be good just based on how much it
smells it's like gym socks that you've
kept in the same bag for three weeks
smells like a crotch it's like you know
what it looks like silent farts that you
like don't hear and they're also your
sleep oh I'm not like that oh I will
kind of oh I'm sorry it's not as bad as
it smells
yeah it's not as bad as it smells like
look I'm sorry eat it cuz cheese but
it's probably my least favorite I didn't
keep going I would also put this into my
cheese cellar I am NOT going in that
cellar
Oh another cheese I was so excited at
the beginning of this yeah
this one really sweats it smells like
canned sardines or juice Christ that one
tastes a lot stronger than it smells
but in a good way it's like spoiled
Swiss when I first put this in my mouth
I thought I was gonna straight throw out
it and then the aftertaste
I was like mmm just all cheeses good
cheese oh you died
I'm gonna actually flip-flop on this and
say the less stinky the cheese the
better it is no no no I like stinky
cheese I appreciate it but I don't want
it inside me just try it and see if you
like it I might be a little more
adventurous with cheese now don't judge
a cheese by its smell I probably
wouldn't eat this on a date I think if
you have this on the date and your
partner's into it you guys are gonna
have really great nasty sex oh yes